when I was younger particularly in  primary school I was bullied because I  was different I know what it's like to  be harassed and misunderstood and  isolated for things that you have no  control over and the reason why I'm  telling you that is because today is do  it for dolly day dolly ever lost her  life because of the devastating effect  that bullying can have on an individual  and I want to take this opportunity to  remind all of you of the impact you can  have on others through your words and  actions and also encourage you to be  positive in the influence that you have  on the people around you take the  opportunity to extend friendship to  write a kind note to someone or just to  be there with someone rather let them be  alone this is an opportunity for all of  us to recognize that Dolly's life will  not be wasted if it has an impact on all  of us to stop bullying speak even if  your voice shakes do it for dolly